so it is time then for the Press preview
our first look at what is on the front
pages and tonight we'll see what's
making the headlines for the broadcaster
and former conservative special advisor
Anita vote and Financial Times political
correspondent Jasmine Cameron very good
evening to both of you we'll speak in a
moment after we've had a look at those
front pages for you beginning with the
front page of the Observer quoting
senior Torres who fear a return to Boris
as PM would risk the conservative
party's death
while the Sunday Times reports that the
right of the party has spurned Boris and
claimed support for Rishi is surging
ahead
it's a different view from the Sunday
Express the papers saying that Boris
Johnson is on track to pull off what it
calls the biggest comeback in political
history
the Sunday Mirror claims that the Tories
are unable to govern themselves
dill or No Deal is the sun on Sunday's
headline the paper claiming Rishi sunak
and Boris Johnson could be working on a
plan which would see one of them become
pm
and the Sunday Telegraph also claiming
that the two leader leading contenders
are being urged to strike a deal to
avert what it calls a conservative Civil
War and we're joined by Anita and
Jasmine great to see you this Sunday
evening uh just one story in town just
one story on the front of all the papers
as you'd expect uh Jasmine why don't you
kick things off for us Sunday Express
picturing there Boris Johnson as he got
off that plane from the Caribbean and as
they say Boris Johnson uh is on course
to pull off the biggest comeback in
political history is he on course to do
that Jasmine
I mean it's quite a triumphant headline
from The Daily Express a little bit
preemptive I mean Boris Johnson
supporters have argued that um he's
reached the threshold of 100 MPS who are
willing to to back him but obviously you
know some of those MPS have come out
publicly I think there's about more than
50 but then some of those MPS are
presumably keeping their cards close to
their chest what is interesting is that
Johnson actually hasn't come out and
said explicitly about his running he
seems to be sort of um trying to get a
sense of where the mood is in the party
where the mood is in the membership and
is trying to figure out how how to
really play things if we think back to
July when he stood down there was always
that sense that he had said goodbye but
it wasn't really a permanent goodbye and
he was he'd be holding out for the next
opportunity to to get back into The Fray
and perhaps this is his opportunity but
I think it's going to be quite
interesting how the rest of the party
navigates the return of you know
potential another Boris Johnson
Premiership obviously he's a pretty
divisive figure and if you think back to
how many ministers and Junior ministers
resigned saying that they they had lost
confidence in his leadership it's
questionable as to whether he is the
individual at this time to really unite
the party yeah um Anita just looking at
the front page of the Observer uh there
were those who are the slightly odd
photographs I thought today Boris
Johnson on the phone there he is looking
a bit miserable with his thumbs up
though uh speaking to an MP presumably
uh trying to to Canvas support but the
Observer saying that top tour is say
that his return would risk the party's
death put it into a death spiral
yes um and and actually this is sort of
gets at some of those tensions and
things that I'm sure Boris Johnson is
weighing up um as it comes into almost
the final day before it's time to start
submitting
um your nomination paper so I imagine
that Boris Shelton hasn't entirely made
up his mind um that really is going to
depend on whether he gets those numbers
now there is some sort of different
rumors swirling about in the papers
tonight about whether or not Boris
Johnson has in fact reached that
threshold what we can say is that 54 55
MPS have publicly said they are backing
Boris Johnson a slightly wonder whether
if a hundred had been reached so few
would be saying that they had backed him
publicly because it it seems like the
nomination paper will be you know
verified and seen by
um the 1922 committee on Monday in any
case but but the key thing is his
supporters seem to have heart to to
think that he might be at he is at the
threshold and that really the the battle
between
um sunak and Johnson uh will be fought
all of tomorrow and into Monday yeah uh
Tom is uh it is running out though isn't
it uh Jasmine and of course Boris
Johnson has to weigh up a couple well he
has to weigh up a lot of things but
particularly uh the fact that he faces
the Privileges committee and does he
really want to be prime minister when
he's got to go through that grilling and
potentially uh be uh be suspended as a
result of it and also um many
conservative MPS or certainly several
publicly are threatening to resign if he
does become pm
yes I think one of the big problems that
Johnson has is that he carries a lot of
political baggage that comes with you
know having been a prime minister that's
had to resign so there's concerns about
the Privileges committee and we heard
from Dominic Robb over the weekend he
said essentially how can Johnson have
any form of credibility when he's got
this hanging over his head and I think
there's a real fear from Tory MPS that
if Johnson is returned um back into
office while this privileges committee
is taking place it will it will really
bring the party back to those dark days
of partygate and all those questions
about what was in the sea gray report
and what was said where and when and
whether or not he lied to Parliament and
actually I don't really think there's
any political appetite for that people
are worried about
um paying for their energy bills they're
worried about Rising mortgages and
actually it probably wouldn't be a good
look for the party to be embroiled in
that Affair again there are also other
things looming such as the covert
inquiry which will obviously shed light
on Johnson's leadership during the
pandemic so there's a lot of issues that
Tori MPS are weighing up that Johnson
will have to weigh up and I think what's
really striking is that a lot of MPS
genuinely blame Johnson for
um you know damaging the reputation of
the party if we think back to a couple
months ago all of the by-election losses
that were sustained under Johnson's
watch there is a lot of skepticism in
the back benches and I think people are
asking themselves why would Johnson want
to BPM is it to genuinely you know is it
in the interests of the UK is there a
sense of Duty that he feels or is it
more of a sort of personal ambition of
his to perhaps finish
um business that he considered
unfinished and so they're weighing up
all these questions at the moment yeah
at the front page of the mirror uh the
Tories can't even govern themselves uh
Anita critics accusing him already of
lying going back to what you were
talking about earlier whether or not he
has got 100 MPS supporting him another
blow for Boris Johnson is that people
like Saji Javid Dominic Robb Kami
badnock uh uh are all put their names
behind Rishi sunak
yes I mean the first two won't be a
surprise but and kemi during the
leadership contest over the summer you
could see signs that she was compelled
by sunax argument
um so but again I mean people like
Charles Moore and the telegraph um
earlier today you know a big backer of
Boris Johnson saying that now is not the
moment Lord David Frost again coming out
and saying actually the moment is for
sunak and not Johnson
um I think it's interesting I probably
slightly disagree with you Jasmine that
the the primary consideration will be
things like the covert inquiry for
instance I think for Boris Johnson he
will not want to fight if he does not
win and I think that that could you know
being a former prime minister and
standing to be prime minister again to
lose that would be quite a big moment
and a kind of big almost
um the the relationship and the
emotional relationship that many
um MPS and party members have to Boris
Johnson is in part because of the
tremendous victory of 2019 but also
because of the manner of his removal and
if there is a contest and it's a
straight fight and Boris Johnson does
not Triumph I think that becomes
incredibly challenging for him and his
sort of Legacy within the conservative
party and there's also the challenge of
course of MP support because there is a
feeling amongst his supporters that if
he goes to the membership he will win
but the challenge then is because you've
got to have this indicative vote that
you may have a vote that sets out in
black and white the number of MPS that
do not prefer Boris Johnson as a first
choice now that could be upended by the
membership they can ignore that
indicative vote but nevertheless it
makes it very very clear when it comes
to managing the Parliamentary party just
how many people would have referred
Boris Johnson not to return so there's a
lot to weigh up I think it's a lot about
reputation as well rather than about
maybe some of the kind of policy
challenges because for him the big self
for boys Johnson is electability and the
ability to sort of defy gravity and I
think that that's what a lot of MPS are
looking for but the Practical elements
of governing are going to be very
challenging if he does try out yeah it's
also intriguing isn't it and talking
about that indicative vote well we may
not even get to that stage uh Jasmine
because there is talk that these two men
which you see like a rose Johnson uh are
uh in talks that they've been discussing
the future maybe uh even this evening uh
or perhaps tomorrow as well
what is that deal gonna be do you think
how could they come to some sort of
agreement
I mean I think it's very plausible that
an agreement could take place I mean I
think the problem for any new leader
coming in at this point is that
effectively the party is so divided if
we look back to what's happened over the
past year we had the beginning of the
year all the issues with partygate and
then concerns about harassment then we
had quite a bitter leadership election
over the summer where effectively the
party has been torn into multiple
different factions and so essentially
there seems to be some sort of a ploy
between
um Johnson and Cena that actually
whoever it is that they rally their
supporters behind them because I think
what is quite interesting is because of
Johnson's win in 2019 there is the
Tories have this huge parliamentary
majority on paper but actually as trust
showed that the the leader doesn't
actually have a working majority to get
legislation and policies through
Parliament and so that will be you know
a key Focus for whoever the next leader
is that actually they need to have MPS
on side they need to ensure that MPS are
aligned with their vision of government
aligned with the direct action in which
they you know they want to take the
economy and so it's inevitable that
there would be some sort of backroom
deals an attempt to to law one supporter
side to another to actually ensure that
the conservative party can actually
govern whoever it is ends up leading
yeah we may get uh more details tomorrow
just 20 seconds Anita from you on this
deal the front of the sun Deal or No
Deal talking about high stake talks
I'm yet to properly discern what a deal
means because uh Boris Johnson has been
prime minister Richie sunac has been
Chancellor I think they would both
concede that that did not work
particularly well
um and so is Boris Johnson would you
therefore be offered Chancellor I I
can't imagine him wanting that role
um so it I'm not sure what it really
means
um but and I and I'm I'm sort of
slightly wondering whether one of them
would want to be anything other than
prime minister given the senior roles
that they've held likewise it's a
different situation where she may you
know having a prominent deal and a
conversation um between her and soon
alcohol Johnson could be a nice unifying
signal for the party part two of The
Press preview Anita and Jasmine still
with us front of the Sunday Times uh
Jasmine I mean there is other news
around none of it particularly uh
optimistic I'm afraid cancer weights
rise to 55 days
yeah it's quite a striking story and I
think it's important to you know as
important as it is to talk about the
state of conservative party and what's
near the ins and outs of Tory Psycho
Drama actually this story is a reminder
that there are some very real issues
facing the country notably the running
of public services and this actually
comes uh quite an interesting time
because we know the chancellor Jeremy
Hunt has essentially said that all
departments you know could be at the
risk of um facing cuts and that includes
the Department of Health and actually
there are all sorts of questions as to
whether the NHS can endure any more
public sector cuts and how the NHS has
been running at the moment because we
know that since the the pandemic but
actually there have been several
headlines whether it's cancer waiting
times or waiting times more generally
indicating that the service is really
struggling to keep up with demand at the
moment and this story in the Sunday
Times just exemplifies that yeah really
uh really depressing this Anita isn't it
just seeing here the UK came 33rd out of
41 developed Nations for cancer
mortality in 2019 according to the oecd
yes um and and really what we're seeing
also is that the the the wait time on
average in the UK is 55 days so this is
quite a long-standing challenge that the
UK um has experienced so that 55 days is
sort of a week longer than it was in
2020 so even sort of during the pandemic
and it's primarily it seems a shortage
challenge that the NHS has been
struggling with for quite a significant
period of time which has obviously been
exacerbated both by pressures on the NHS
and challenges um you know recruiting
retaining staff um and just further
underpins the point that
um the the challenges in the economy in
the in the UK and many of these things
are being experienced across Europe too
are so so acute and that it's very
difficult to see how the UK navigate a
successful path out of them especially
in a moment where there is such
sensitivity to the UK's public finances
that there really isn't that level of
flexibility that that the government can
provide around spending to different
departments and I I certainly wouldn't
wish to be Jeremy Hunt who I believe
honestly even with you know the new
prime minister coming in Jeremy Hunt has
the toughest job in government right now
because he has a week in which to come
up with the kinds of scales of cuts that
are completely unprecedented in 2010
that George Osborne and David Cameron
had to cut 24 billion we're now talking
about potentially 40 billion like how is
half such as some to be found I really
think it's going to be an enormously
difficult time for the UK and for
different departments yeah which leads
us on to a story in the Sunday Express
which is also actually health related
Jasmine isn't it um festive staff crisis
on the High Street this Christmas but
retail retailers are struggling to find
shop workers but they fear that record
NHS waiting lists are partly to blame
simply because what potential workers
are too ill to get to work
yeah it's a really interesting story
actually because it touches upon the
fact that the UK has a lot of people I
think it runs up into the millions who
are um off work due to long-term
sickness and obviously that links to the
accessibility of NHS Healthcare and how
easy it is for people to see doctors and
get certain illnesses treated and it
speeds the fact that actually you know
all of this is interconnected if we have
a Health Service that is um struggling
to to meet the demand that does seep
into the wider economy as a whole and
even this is you know this is one small
example of um stores that will be
struggling to recruit during Christmas
but actually some of the numbers
um quoted in the story are actually
quite big and it's saying that vacancies
are running out to thousands so actually
this could potentially be quite a tricky
period for for businesses who are
already struggling with energy costs you
will already be trying to make sure that
they can attempt to get a profit this
year in quite a tricky economic period
for us all okay uh talking of uh three
times ahead Anita we've just got one
minute left to talk about uh schools and
their concerns
it's the same story really
um so the National Association of head
teachers is saying that nine out of ten
schools will be running out of cash
um and Paul Whiteman the general
secretary says you know there are no
easy fixes left um in terms of these the
cuts that they would have to make would
start affecting things like Staffing
levels and I think you know no easy
fixes left is almost Jeremy Hunt's motto
too and I think it would be the exact
same situation that labor would be
facing um were they in power really
there is very there are very there's no
low hanging fruit that I'm aware of left
across every Department in government
and yet every Department in government
is going to need to be able to find
savings okay your challenge for the next
hour to find something a little bit more
cheerful uh to finish the day with Anita
Jasmine thank you both very much uh
indeed your thoughts on all those
stories let's